اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه اخباريه مفصله
من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
رغم الهدنه الممدده تحليق حربي في سماء
العاصمه الخرطوم والاشتباكات تتوسع في ام
درمان
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع يتبادلان
الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه المعلنه
السفينه السعوديه امانه ترفد اكبر عمليه
اجراء للرعايه الاجانب من السودان منذ
بدايه الحرب
روسيا تهدد بولندا بعد مصادره مبنى بل
مبنى مدرسه روسيه في العاصمه وارسو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تغطيه العربيه مستمره
للوضع في السودان حيث تدخل الحرب اسبوعها
الثالث مع تواصل اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم رغم
موافقه الطرفين على هدنه خامسه لوقف اطلاق
النار سواء الخرطوم شهدت في اليوم الخامس
عشر من المواجهات تحليقا كثيفا لطائره
حربيه في وقت سمعت بل سمعت اصوات ذوي
المدفعيه ومضادات الطائرات اما في مدينه
ام درمان فقد ادى سقوط قذيفه على احد
المنازل الى مقتل شخص على الاقل
[تصفيق]
في اخر تطورات المتعلقه بالحرب الدائره
بين المكونين العسكريين في السودان قال
الجيش السوداني في بيان رسمي انما حصل كان
محاوله النفاش الاستيلاء على الحكم بقوه
المتمردين واكد البيانو ان محاوله متمررين
او اعوانهم من عملاء الداخل والخارج في
التسويق لمشروعهم القائم على تزييف
الحقائق قد فشلت واشار بيان الجيش الا ان
المعركه وحدت الشعب وقواته المسلحه وزادت
بل وقواته المسلحه وزادت من حيث ابناء
الوطن على اهميه بقاء قواته المسلحه كما
اكد البيان على العمل على تهيئه الظروف
المناسبه لكل اجهزه الدوله من استئناف
عملها وعوده الحياه لطبيعتها باسرع وقت
ممكن
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت من جانبها الجيش
السوداني بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه عبر
مهاجمه مراكزها وعدد من الاحياء السكنيه
في الخرطوم بواسطه الطيران والمدفعيه هذا
وجددت قوات الدعم السريع في بيان لها
التزامها الكامل بالهدنه الانسانيه
المعلنه لفتح ممرات امنه للمواطنين لقضاء
احتياجاتهم ولتسهيل عمليات الاجلاء
الطيران
نقابه اطباء السودان في تقييدها اليومي
افادت بارتفاع ضحايا الاشتباكات في البلاد
الى 411 قتيلا من المدنيين واصابه 2023
اخرين واوضحت النقابه في بيان ان الاقتتال
الاخير في مدينه الجنينه اوقعت ساعه
وثمانين قتيلا مشيره الى انه لا يوجد حصر
دقيق لعدد الاصابات واضافت النقابه ان
جميع المستشفيات في المدينه خارج الخدمه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا لم يخرطوم يظلموا الى الكاتب
الصحفي محمد شمس الدين اهلا بك محمد معناه
في هذه الساعه الاخباريه بدايه عطفا على
وجودك في الخرطوم كيف يمكنك ان تصفنا
الوضع الان الى اي مدى هناك هدوء او
اشتباكات سواء مستمره او متقطعه في
العاصمه بين الطرفين المتقاتلين
تحياتي لك احمد المشاهدين اينما كانوا
يعني الوضع في الخرطوم حاله من الهدوء
الحذر ما بين الطرفين في هذه الساعه
ما سبق الابتعاد كان يعني لا يختلف كثيرا
عن ايام الاذن السابقه الخروقات منذ ساعات
الصباح بعد شروق الشمس اصوات اطلاق
النيران كانت مسموعه في مناطق واسعه من
احياء الخرطوم الشرقيه والغربيه
واعلم عبده فان الاشتباكات الان يعني في
داخل الاحياء الشرقيه حي الرياض حي بري كل
هذه البنادق يستمع الى اصوات الاطلاقات
فيها بشكل واضح جدا هذه الاحياء ايضا شهدت
بالامس اشتباكات عنيفه وكان حي بري مسرحا
من مسارح المواجهات وكانت هناك قذائف سقطت
داخل الاحياء وتناقل بعض الصور لهذه
الحوادث ايضا لم يسلم من هذه
المواجهات وهذه الضربات المكثفه تتواجد
يعني عدد كبيره من عناصر الدم السريع في
تلك المنطقه ايضا ما زالت السيطره في
مناطق واسعه من احياء الخرطوم لقوات الدعم
السريع في شرق المطار والقياده العامه
وغربي كذلك هناك معاناه كبيره جدا فيما
يتعلق بالحصول على المواد الغذائيه في
مختلف مناطق
العاصمه الوضع في ام درمان كذلك حاله
الاشتباكات لم تتوقف هذه المدينه يوجد في
غربها قاعده وادي سيدنا العسكريه وهي
قاعده استراتيجيه يعني تستخدم الان كبديل
لمطار الخرطوم لعمليات الاجلاء المعروفه
ان الطائرات التي انطلقت من الخرطوم
وهي تحمل
يعني عائلات
عائلات
الدبلوماسيه انطلقت من مطر وادي سيدنا
العسكري من القاعده الجويه هناك الى
بورسودان ومن ثم اتجهت بهم الى دولهم سواء
عبر البحر بدايه ثم وصلنا الى جده
وطبعا الامر يعني كما هو فيما يتعلقن
الوضع العام للمستشفيات هناك قوائم بدات
تظهر لبعض المستشفيات ومراكز خدمات غسيل
الكلى هناك حاله من حالات التاقلم الان ما
بين المدنيين في ايجاد الحلول والبدائل
فيما تبقى او فيما بين من تبقى من
المدنيين في الخ
رطوم طيب محمد لماذا في تقديرك يعني هذا
الفشل المتكرر للهودن السابقه بعضها فشل
ربما في ساعته الاول وبعضها استمر ربما
لايام قليله او ساعات قليله ثم انهارت هذه
الهدى هل هي عوده السبب الى او المسؤوليه
الى الطرفين الى احدهما فقط يعني هو الذي
ربما يتحمل القدر الاكبر من انهيار هذه
الهدن
اتابع احمد بعض التحليلات عبر مختلف
ووسائط التواصل الاجتماعي ما بين بعض
المحللين وبعض الخبراء بعض القراءات التي
تشير الى ان وجود الطرف الثالث في هذه
المعركه والذي يعني يبدو ظاهرا للعيان وهو
الطرف
المرتبط بالنظام السابق عناصر النظام
السابق الذين ظهروا على الخط في هذه
المعركه بوضوح شديد
وبداوا في بدايه المطاف وهم يدعمون
المؤسسه العسكريه ثم يعني مع هذا الوضع
الذي لم يتم فهمه حتى هذه اللحظه عدم تمكن
من حسم المعركه حتى الان بدا بدات حاله
التذمر الشديد الان تتضح كاوصات هذه
المجموعات التي دفعت بمليشياتها الخاصه
ويعني هي لا تخفي ذلك بطبيعه الحال وتظهر
لقطات واضحه على التواصل الاجتماعي لهذه
العناصر بدات في تهديد
قاده الجيش بانهم سيقومون بحسم المعركه
حتى الان على الرغم من انهم هم يعني يعني
في مقدمه هذه القوات الان ولم يتمكنوا من
حسم المعركه ربما هذا الامر صعب من عمليه
التواصل ما بين القياده المؤسسه العسكريه
وهذه المجموعات التي يعني تتخذ في بعض
الحالات قرارات الفرديه بحسب بعض القراءات
قراءات المحللين العسكريين في هذا الاطار
كذلك
ايضا من يرى ان تحميل نظام السابقا
المسؤوليه هو لا يخرج عن كونه شماعه تعلق
عليها اسباب الفشل الذي لازم العمليه
السياسيه في السنوات الماضيه ما رايك في
هذا الطرح
الامر مختلف يعني هنا معركه بدات قبل
حوالي اسبوعين
ومعطياتها كانت مختلفه هناك حاله من حالات
الاستفاف وراء المؤسسه العسكريه من مختلف
قطاعات المدنيين بكل اطيافهم خاصه من
لديهم خلاف او راي فيما يتعلق باداره
المؤسسه العسكريه من المجموعه التي تقود
الان هناك بعض القراءات التي خرجت مؤخرا
وتقول بان هناك حاله من حالات يعني عدم
التنسيق في حتى قياده المعركه الاعلاميه
والكفه يقولون بانها ترجح للطرف الاخر
نتابع ذلك في يعني تواجد هذه العناصر
عناصر الدعم السريع في الشارع عبر الصوت
والصوره بينما الطرف الاخر فقط عبر
البيانات المكتوبه هذه كلها مؤشرات وعناصر
مهمه لابد ان تستحق في قراءه محمد ساعود
اليكم هذه الساعه الاخباريه
مشاهدينا بعد 15 يوما من القتال العيني في
ابدى قائد قوات الدعم السريع في مقابله مع
قناه بي بي سي استعداده لاجراء مفاوضات مع
قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان بشرط وقف
اطلاق النار وقال حملتي لهيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه انه طالب بالهدنه منذ اليوم
الاول للحرب وان قواته بدات بفتح ممرات
انسانيه داخل مناطق سيطرتها
وفي تصريح للعربيه قال يوسف عزه المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان قال ان قواته سيطرت على 90% من
ولايه الخرطوم وانها تستطيع الصمود في
المعارك لسنوات يوسف عزت لفتاه الى ان
المعركه فرضت على الدعم السريع وان وقف
اطلاق النار مرتبط بتنفيذ الجيش لذلك واكد
عزه في لقائه مع العربيه ان البرهان لا
يدير المعركه ولا يستطيع وقف النار على حد
قوله
قوات الدعم السريع قادره على الصمود قادره
على الصمود واثبتت خلال اسبوعين من الحرب
المتواصله انها ليست مليشيا انها ليست
قوات منظمه تتبع خطط عسكريه
مرتبه لدينا وساطه من
امريكا ومدعومه من السعوديه لدينا وساطه
من العقاد لدينا وساطه من دول كثيره صديقه
ومنظمات ندرس كل هذه الخيارات ونحن
ولا نزيد استمرار الحرب ولا نريد معاناه
شعبنا
اي هنالك حل ياسس لسلام دائم
بالمقابل اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بادخال اسلحه وجنود لمستشفى
الخرطوم وبتحويل المستشفى وبعض المدارس
لسكنات عسكريه وجاء في البيان ان
المتمردين مستمرون بقصف الخرطوم واندرمان
لاجبار السكان على الاخلاء لافتا لان
القصف العشوائي مستمر في محيط قياده بحري
والقياده العامه والدفاع الجوي واضاف
الجيش انه نفذ عمليات اجلاء عبر مطاري
وادي سيدنا وبورسودان لرعايا بعض الدول
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسله
عربيه سالم الهاشمي وكيف يبدو المشهد في
الخرطوم في هذه الساعه
اهلا احمد وبكل الساده المشاهدين المشهد
يبدو هناك هدوء حذر بين كافه الاطراف في
الشارع هناك حركه شبه طبيعيه للمواطنين في
مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم عوده بعض
الاسواق للعمل نتحدث عن الاسواق التي
تتعامل اليوم باليوم هي سواق الخضار
والفواكه وبدات حركه فيها ايضا تبدو شبه
طبيعيه لكن في مناطق متباعده قليلا
تبدو الحياه شبه طبيعيه في مناطق متفرقه
ربما تكون هذه الهدنه حتى الان من صباح
اليوم هي الاكثر هدوءا بالنسبه للعاصمه
الخرطوم وهناك تحركات للمواطنين او تحرك
المواطنين حركتهم الشبه الطبيعيه لجلب
احتياجاتهم وايضا الحركه للخروج من
العاصمه الخرطوم كذلك ايضا تبدو طبيعيه
كذلك حتى الان
لا وجود لمظاهر عسكريه واضحه لا وجود
الاشتباكات واضحه عدا في مناطق قليله جدا
مقارنه بالايام الماضيه لكن الان ايضا عبر
الشاشه هو هذه الصور المباشره نرى فيها
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من منطقه ما في وسط
الخرطوم لا ندري هل هي نتيجه الاشتباكات
في وقت سابق ام هي لحريق جديد في العاصمه
معلومات سالم
نعم ما تراه في الشاشه الان هي مجموعه من
الحرائق اغلبها في المنطقه الصناعيه في
مدينه بحري ومنذ الامس كان قد اندلعت
مجموعه من الحرائق في هذه المنطقه
الصناعيه
هذه المنطقه الصناعيه تعرضت لهجوم
متكرر في الايام الماضيه او منذ اندلاع
هذه الاشتباكات
وربما هذا من الامور المؤسفه جدا ان تكون
هنالك هذه الكلمه الهائل من المصانع وكذلك
الشركات وهي منطقه صناعيه بالفعل تمد
الخرطوم والسودان كله بالعديد من المنتجات
باشكالها وانواعها بالامس لاحظنا اندلاع
حريق في احد المصانع في مدينه بحري كنا
بالقرب منه كذلك لم نستطع التحقق من اسم
المصنع لكن واحد من المصانع في المنطقه
الصناعيه كذلك حريق اخر ايضا في المنطقه
الصناعيه لكن في اطرافها الاخرى بالقرب من
مدينه او بالقرب من منطقه كافوري كذلك
مربع سته هذه المنطقه منطقه حيويه جدا
حقيقه الحرائق التي تندلع فيها
اصبحت شبه مهجوره الان في تلك المناطق
يعني غالب السكان في منطقه كافور المتاخمه
للمنطقه الصناعيه هجر تلك المناطق بحكم
انها اصبحت غير امنه وفي هذه في هذا
التوقيت هذه هي الحرائق يعني ربما كانت
هناك اشتباكات صباح اليوم سمعت اصوات
بالقرب من المنطقه الصناعيه صباح اليوم في
هذه المنطقه
ربما تكون هذه الحرائق جراء هذه
الاشتباكات في المناطق المتفرقه من مدينه
بحري لكنها احمد لابد ان ننوه لانها
بالمقارنه بكل الايام الماضيه ربما اكثر
الايام هدوءا حتى الان طيب ايضا في
اليوميه الماضيين سالم كانت هناك انباء
متداوله حول بدايه او انطلاق اعمال صيانه
مطار الخرطوم الدولي وامكانيه عودته
الخدمه خلال ايام قليله عطفا على الاضرار
التي وصفت بالمحدوده يعني في هذه في هذه
البيانات او الاخبار المتداوله هل من جهه
رسميه قد اكدت هذه المعلومات املفتها او
نفتها
بالنسبه لمطار الخرطوم لم نستطع الاقتراب
من مطار الخرطوم لان مطار الخرطوم معلوم
انه هو والقصر الرئاسي وكذلك القياده
العامه هذه المناطق تنتشر فيها القوات
بكثافه من الصعوبه جدا للوصول الى هناك
لمعرفه حقيقه ما يحدث على الارض حتى نكون
اكثر دقه لكن بالنسبه للمعلومات التي
وردتها تم تداولها بشكل كبير لم تاتي
الجهه الرسميه وهي جهه الجهه المسؤوله عن
مطار الخرطوم اداره مطار الخرطوم لم تتحدث
عن صيانه ولم تتحدث عن بدء الاعمال حتى
الان بشكل رسمي لم يردنا هذا الخبر على
الاقل يعني فيما يتعلق ببيان رسمي من مطار
الخرطوم او من جهه اخرى رسميه تصدر قرانا
ببدء العمل في مطار الخرطوم مع خالص
الامنيات بان يبدا فعلا مطار الخرطوم
بالعمل وان تعود الحياه لطبيعتها بكل
تاكيد عطفا على ذلك ايضا هناك الان صور مت
بشكل واسع على انه الشرطه السودانيه او
قسم من الشرطه السودانيه وهو الاحتياط
المركزي هناك صور كثيره الان تملا الميديا
بالحديث عن عوده الشرطه لحمايه الممتلكات
والمنشات كذلك كل هذه الامور اذا صحت لانه
الى الان ايضا لم يصدر بيان من الجيش او
من الشرطه عن بدء
اعمالها يعني ان تبدا في عملها كشرطه او
الجيش كذلك لم يصدر بيانا رسميا لكن هذا
متداول بشكل واسع الان في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بصور متداوله للشرطه السودانيه
انها ستبدا في حمايه المنشات والممتلكات
نحن نتحدث عن الاخبار الايجابيه المركزي
فعلا الشعبيه والمواطن يحتاجها في هذا
التوقيت
نعم لكنها تتبع للشرطه وهي تتبع وزاره
الداخليه كذلك هو قسم من الشرطه اسم
الاحتياطي المركزي وهو معروف لكن اذا صحت
هذه الانباء فهي تعتبر من الامبال ايجابيه
الجيده التي يمكن ان تحقق الطمانينه
للمواطنين في ظل الرعب والخوف الذي يعيشه
المواطن في هذه الايام عمليات النزوح
والانتقال من العاصمه الخرطوم سالم كيف
تسير الان والى اين تشد الرحال يعني اكثر
الولايات او المدن التي تشد اليها الرحال
في هذه الايام
[موسيقى]
بعد وصول الى الولايات نهرانين الانتقال
لولايه الى الولايه الشماليه او الخروج
بعد ذلك الى جمهوريه مصر شكرا لك يا سالم
تفضل بالبقاء معي ساعود اليك من جديد في
سياق هذه الساعه الاخباريه والان مشاهدينا
مع دخول المواجهات يومها الخامس عشر تواصل
عواصم الدول اجلال رعاياها والهاربين من
قتال الدائر في السودان منذ اسبوعين
السعوديه مشاهدينا تمثل نقطه عبور رئيسيه
لعدد من هذه الدول عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي
وقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
[موسيقى]
في هذا السياق قالت الخارجيه السعوديه
انها اجلت
4,738 شخصا من السودان من رعايه 96 دوله
وذلك منذ بدء الاشتباكات في السودان كما
اشارت الخارجيه السعوديه الى انه تم اجلاء
139 مواطنا سعوديا من السودان حيث يتم
توفير الاحتياجات الاساسيه للرعايه تمهيدا
لتسهيل مغادرتهم الى بلدانهم
قبل ذلك قال العقيد مسفر الجريني المتحدث
الرسمي لحرس الحدود السعودي في تصريحات
للعربيه حين حرس الحدود في ميناء جده سخر
جميع الامكانيات البشريه والماديه
والتقنيه لاستقبال لضيوف عمليه الاجلاء من
السودان حيث وصلت سفينه صينيتان تحملان
رعايا من الصين وباكستان
حرس الحدود مهام من ضمن الاعمال والمهام
المنوطه بوزاره الداخليه والقطاعاتها
المشاركه في تقديم المساعده في عمليات
الاجلاء
المواطنين او الرعايه الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه من السودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي والتي سنحت لهم حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
عمليات الاجلاء الى حتى وصولهم الى جده
ومن ثم المغادره الى بلادهم بكل امن
وسلامه يقوم حرس الحدود بالعديد من المهام
من ضمنها حفظ الامن والسلامه داخل الميناء
وكذلك
المنطقه المحيطه به كما يقوم حرس الحدود
بتنظيم الحافلات والمركبات داخل الميناء
لتحقيق الامن والسلامه للجميع طبعا سخر
حرس حدود جميع الامكانيات الماديه
والبشريه والتقنيه لخدمه هؤلاء القادمين
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده ينضم الينا مراسله العربيه سلطان
السلمي اهلا بك سلطان واخر ما ذكرني
معطيات حول عمليات اجلاء الرعايه الاجانب
في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه تفضل
قبل الخوض في هذه التفاصيل استوقفني هذا
المشهد لهذا الطفل الرضيع الذي يبلغ عمره
15 يوم فقط او هذه الطفله التي يبلغ عمرها
15 يوم فقط تم اجلائها من ميناء بورت
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه كما
نشاهد الان لم يصل عمره الى فقط 15 يوم
نشاهد اطفال ورعايه وذوي احتياجات خاصه
تقوم السلطات السعوديه
باجلائهم بشكل مباشر من ميناء بورت
السودان هذه الطفله نتعرف على والدتها انا
رابعه العدويه البشرى مصطفى من سكان
كافوري
استطعتم مجلاه هذا الطفل وكيف نجا من كافه
الاحداثها حتى المستشفى الحمد لله يعني
كنا في كارفور الضرب كان عندنا من فوق
وتحت فاضطرينا أطلع الكتاب لعمر جديد
الحمد لله الحمد لله جزاكم الله خير انتم
تم التعامل معاها في في السفينه بكل
الرحمن بكل موده بكل رحمه بكل حب والله
الحمد لله ربنا يجزيكم كل خير عنا يا رب
خفتي عليها كثير والله خفت في الشمس كانت
الشمس حاره مره داخله على الباخره
اما انا والله كله تمام
الله يكرمكم يعني زي ما انتم مشاهدي
اللقطات المباشره هذه الطفله عمرها 15 يوم
الان سوف نحاول استضافه يا عمي اتفضل يا
عم سوف الان نعم بالراحه عليها يا امي
بالراحه بالراحه
كتب لها عمر جديد الحمد لله الحمد لله
المستشفى اللي ولدت فيها انضربت مستشفى
الساحه ما اعرف اذا انضربت ولا لا لكن
يعني احنا طلعنا قبل يومين بس من الاحداث
نحن في الخرطوم كافوري طردت لقصف كثير
والله جاتنا الطلقات جاتني في البيت وصلت
البيت يعني
ما قدمت لطلب الاجلاء الى السفاره تعاملوا
بشكل مباشر بسبب الحاله اللي معاي على طول
يعني ما اخذ صراحه اي وقت
يعني صراحه احسن معامله وب
سرعه الحمد لله اكثر لحظه انت قلقتي فيها
على طفلتك والله لحظه
[موسيقى]
هو موجود في نفس الغرفه
فكان يعني خوف شديد الحمد لله احنا طلعنا
سالمين يعني بعد ما شفته قاعد ملك فيصل
وصلت للمياه الاقليميه السعوديه ايش اول
احساس بادر لذه الحمد لله
مواليد المملكه واحنا عايشين هنا واهلينا
لهم اكثر من 30 سنه فالحمد لله دائما
المملكه ايوه اشكال
احنا بس التخصص ايوه يعني احنا اصلا
مواليد كلهم مولودين الحمد لله فما شفنا
المملكه الا كل خير الحمد لله شكرا شكرا
يعني كما شاهدنا اطفال رضع بعمر لا يتجاوز
الخمسه عشره يوما تقوم الحكومه السعوديه
باجلائهم بشكل واعطاهم الاولويه بشكل
مباشر نظرا لحالتهم الصحيه وظروفهم
الاجتماعيه الان كما ننوه انه تبقى فقط
اعداد قليله على عمليه انزال هؤلاء
الرعايه من هم علامات السفينه امانه التي
كان على متنها 20 امواطن سعودي
و1,86 من الرعايه الاجانب بمختلف جنسيتهم
ومن ضمنهم 65
مواطن ايراني كان في استقبالهم الممثلين
الدبلوماسيين وعدد ممثلين الخارجيه
السعوديه كذلك تم اجلاء في هذه الرحله 155
شخص من موظفي الامم المتحده من ميناء
بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده في رحله استغرقت قرابه الاثنى عشره
ساعه ايضا تم التعامل مع عدد من الحالات
الطبيه والصحيه من قبل هيئه للاحمر
السعودي وكذلك مركبات الاسعاف الخاصه بقوه
بمستشفى القوات المسلحه
بجده هنالك حالات مختلفه مثل انخفاض الضغط
وغير ايضا نشاهد العسكر السعوديين يقومون
بمساعده كبار السن ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه
من خلال حمل حقائبهم ودفع العربات
المتحركه تبقت اعداد محدوده جدا تم انهاء
اجراءات سفر عدد كبير منهم يصل الى 600
شخص من قبل المديريه العامه للجوازات التي
عملت الحزمه من البرامج والاستثناءات
الخاصه بهذا الراعي نظره لظروفهم
الانسانيه وتم نقل عدد من هؤلاء الرعايه
الاسطول من الحافلات خاصه سلطات السعوديه
للقلي من مساكنهم بمدينه جده حتى يتسنى
انهاء بقيه الاجراءات والسفر الى بلدانهم
خلال اليومين القادمين نؤكد انه هذه
السفينه رقم 12 من السفن البحريه العسكريه
السعوديه والسفن المدنيه السعوديه التي
قامت بعمليات اجلاء منذ الايام الماضيه
اعداد من الطلبات استقبلها الحكومه
السعوديه من كافه الدول العربيه
والاجنبيه لاجلاء رعاياها في ظل الظروف
الساخنه هناك في الخرطوم والولايات
التابعه لها وكذلك وفرت السفاره السعوديه
بالتنسيق مع كافه الاطراف هنالك ممرات
امنه من الخرطوم الى من الى مدينه بورت
السودان التي تبعد عن الخرطوم 850 كيلو
متر وفرت قامت بتوفير ممرات امنه وصخره
عدد كبير من الموظفين لتامين هؤلاء
الرعايه حتى يصل الى ميناء بورتسودان
وتقوم بنقلهم السفن الحربيه والمدنيه
السعوديه الى قاره الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده تم استقبالهم كما نشاهد بالورد
والحلوى وايضا الملفت تنوع الحالات
العمريه والجنسيات في علامه هذه السفينه
التي تقل 20 او نقلت او اجلت 20 مواطن
سعودي
و1866 مواطن اجنبي تم تقديم كافه
التسهيلات الخاصه بالاء الرعايه تم
استقبالهم سفراء وقناصل الدول الاجنبيه
للتاكل من سلامتهم وصحتهم وانهاء
اجراءاتهم على ارض قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه بجده
الطيب سلطان يعني ماذا نعرف ايضا عن طبيعه
الاجراءات المتخذه بعد وصولها اولاء
الرعايه الى ميناء جده وتسهيلات المقدمه
لهم حتى مغادراتهم الاراضي السعوديه ما
الذي يتخذ بحقهم
[موسيقى]
قامت السلطات السعوديه ممثله في وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه وعدد من قطاعات الامنيه
ومن بمقدمتها القوات البحريه السعوديه او
حتى المديريه العامه للجوازات والجمارك في
تقديم حزمه من التسهيل البرامج والتسهيلات
واعطاء تاشيرات استثنائيه لهؤلاء الرعايه
لدخولهم الى الاراضي السعوديه وانهاء
اجراءات سفر دخولهم في ظرف ساعه واحده فقط
ومن ثم ينتقلون بعد ذلك الى اماكنهم
بمرافقه عدد من الموظفين السعوديين للتاكد
العمليات تسكينهم وتلبيه كافه احتياجاتهم
حتى يتسلل لهم السفر الى بلدانهم كما
شاهدنا اسرع عصر يوم امس سفر 379 شخص من
الرعايه الصينيين عبر طائره بوينج تربل
السفن الطائره التابعه للخطوط الصينيه من
مطار الملك عبد الدولي بجده الى العاصمه
الصينيه في رحله سوف تستغرق عشره استغرقت
عشره الساعات بعد ان تم اجلائهم من ميناء
السودان الى مدينه جده واخذوا قرابه اليوم
ونصف اليوم حتى انه اجراءاته مستعدوا
للسفر ايضا في مطار الملك عبد العزيز
الدولي بجده هنالك اسحاله استنفار كبيره
لاستقبال هؤلاء الرعايه وانهاء اجراءاتهم
بشكل مباشر وسريع جدا ايضا الملفت اليوم
هنا وجود عدد كبير من القيادات الامنيه
بمختلف القطاعات العسكريه للتاكد من
عمليات الانزال وسلامة هؤلاء الرعايه حتى
ان يصلوا الى مساكنهم في مدينه جده على
متن هذه السفينه تم تقديم كافه تم تقديم
كافه التمويل الغذائي
والمشروبات وما شابه ذلك وكذلك العياده
الطبيه التي تعمل طوال الساعه طوال
الساعات السفر حتى يصلوا الى بر الامان
هنا على متن سفينه امانه والتي حملت
الامانه من ميناء بورت سودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه في جده نشاهد الان هذه
اللقطات اطفال بمختلف المراحل العمريه
والسيدات وكبار سن
ذوي الاحتياجات الخاصه التي يتم تعامل
معهم بشكل كبير جدا وبشكل دقيق حتى
يستطيعوا الوصول والنزول وتقديم الخدمات
المناسبه لهم طوال الرحله هذه الرحله هي
رقم 12 بعد ان كانت هنالك عشره سفن حربيه
سعوديه تابع للقوات البحريه السعوديه
وسفينتين مدنيه وهي كانت سفينه امانه
التجاريه المدنيه التابعه للحكومه
السعوديه
لاستيعاب اكبر عدد ممكن من هؤلاء الرعايه
باختلاف جنسيتهم واعمارهم ونؤكد ان عمليات
الاجلاء مستمره خلال الساعات القادمه
والايام القادمه في ظل الطلبات الكبيره
التي استقبلتها الحكومه السعوديه
لاجلاء هؤلاء الرعايه بالتنسيق مع
حكوماتهم الاجنبيه هنالك لاسيما للحكومه
السعوديه التي قامت باكبر عمليات الاجلاء
منذ بدء الازمه واكبر دليل او شاهد على
هذه العمليه
سفينه امانه التي يصل عددها الى
1606,866
شخص وعشرين سعودي ممكن نستضيف معنا احدى
السيدات نتعرف عليك
من السودان انا بشكر ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان
وبشكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه انا جيت
انا واولادي
اربعه اولاد ثلاثه
خلصت وانا ما توقعت ان انا اخش المملكه
لانه بصراحه يعني السودان بقى في دمار
شديد ما صدقت لانه الزياره خلصت الحمد لله
انه دخلنا نحن بخير وبشكر والله مشهوره
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه مواقف صعب
والله العظيم عشنا في خوف وفي رعب شديد
يعني صراحه وعيالي طبيعي حتى الباب لو ضرب
يا ماما دي طلقه يا ماما دي ده انا وقعت
يعني طبيعي احنا تحت السراير طبيعي في انه
ما في نوم ثلاثه اربعه يوم ما من نوم
يعني
ذهنك لما شفتي القاعده البحريه والعسكر
السعوديه صراحه ما صدقت انا انا مين خروج
من بورسودان انا ما ظبطته ما قالي روحي
قاعده كم يوم في بورس لكن الحمد لله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه شكرا لكم الحمد
لله على السلامه ونورت السعوديه يعني
اتعرف عليك ممكن اخذ الطفله معانا تفضلي
تعالي يا حلوه ايش كاتبه يعني كاتبه يعني
كاتبه على قميصها شكرا للمملكه هذا نموذج
من الامتنان والتقدير لهؤلاء الرعايه
للحكومه السعوديه على التسهيلات والخدمات
التي قدمتها وفوق ذلك ايضا ايضا مشاهده
الطفله ايضا هي كاتبه من اللي كتب لك على
صدرك هذا
شكرا شكرا سلطان اسمك وكم عمرك
شمس الدين احمد محمد ناصر شكرا لك شكرا
نعم شكرا لك سلطان اذا على على هذه الصور
الرائعه وتحييتنا لك ولجميع ضيوفك من خلال
شاشه العربيه شكرا لك
معنا في متابعه وسنكون معك في متابعه في
النشاط المقبله ايضا الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده كنت معنا مراسل العربيه سلطان السلمي
بمنظمه الامم المتحده بمنطقه شرق الاوسط
تامر حموده في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال
ان الحكومه السعوديه قدمت كل الدعم اللازم
لعمليه اخلاء الموظفين من ميناء بورسودان
الى ميناء جده بجهود السلطات السعوديه
الحكومه السعوديه قدمت كل الدعم اللازم
لاخلاء عمليه اخلاء موظفين من اول ميناء
بورسودان لغايه ما وصلوا بناء جده ومن
ميناء جده استقبلته من الحكومه السعوديه
مع
المتحده الموجوده في المملكه وتم
استضافتهم وتم تسهيل عمليه خروجهم من
ميناء جده الى مطار جده وتم نقلهم الى
مكان اخر احنا من ناحيه الامم المتحده
احنا شايفين مجهود جبار من الحكومه
السعوديه لمساعده كل اللاجئين
المحتاجين الاخلاء من السودان
هذا ووصل الطائره تقل اكثر من 300 واربعين
مواطنا صينيا تم اجلائهم من السودان عبر
السعوديه الى الصين حيث كان من بين
المواطنين الصينيين الموجودين علامات
الطائره مدرسون في معهد كونفشيوس وموظفون
في شركات مملوكه للدوله بحسب وسائل اعلام
صينيه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الاوكرانيه اجلاء 87
من مواطنيها معظمهم من الطيارين وفني
الطائرات وعائلاتهم وذلك ضمن 138 مدنيا في
المجمل من بينهم مواطنون من جهدها وبيرو
من جهه اخرى لم تعلن روسيا بعد عن اي
اجلاء لاعضاء سفارتها او رعاياها من
الخرطوم وقال المتحدث باسم الكرب ان الروس
في السودان على اتصال الوثيق
مؤكدا ان المشاورات التجري على مدار
الساعه
في هذا الاطار اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
والدفاع في فرنسا في بيان مشترك ان طائره
فرنسيه اجلت موظفين من الامم المتحده
والمنظمات الانسانيه من السودان وجددت
فرنسا مناشدتها الاطراف السودانيه لوقف
الاخت التاليه والعوده للحوار السياسي
يذكر انه هو منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان اجلت القوات المسلحه الفرنسيه
اكثر من الف شخص من بينهم 2006 فرنسيا
نشير هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه الفريق البرهان الجيش
السوداني ملتزم بالعمليه السياسيه التي
تقود لقيام سلطه مدنيه في سياق هذه النشره
ايضا مشاهدينا وبدورها اعلنت بريطانيا عن
نهايه رحلات الاجلاء من السودان اعتبار من
اليوم السبت وذلك بعدما اجدد اكثر من 1500
شخص حتى الان وكانت الحكومه البريطانيه
اعلنت الثلاثاء الماضي عن بدء اجلاء
مواطنها بعد موافقه طرفي الصراع على وقف
اطلاق النار لمده 72 ساعه واعطاء الاولويه
لاجلاء من يحملون جوازات سفر بريطانيه
والاسره التي تضم اطفالا وكبار السن الذين
يعانون من ظروف صحيه
اجلت تشاد في غضون 48 ساعه
351 من مواطنيها الذين حصلوا في القتال
الدائري في السودان بعد وصول طائره ثالثه
الى انجي مهنه على متنها 130 راكبا وكشف
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه ابراهيم ادم
محمد عن استقبال 130 عائدا بينهم خمسه عشر
طفلا و 34 مسنا رافقتهم فرق وكاله الهجره
التابعه للامم المتحده التي احصل عددهم
هذا وكانت رحلتان جويتان مخصصان للاجلاء
وصلت الى العاصمه مساء الخميس من بورسودان
وكان علامه طائرتين
221 شاديا
اطفال
[موسيقى]
طبعا يعني السودان والخرطوم
يعني اسوا من يعني حرب حرب يعني
منذ بدايه الصراعي كان شارع الشقله في حي
الفتح حامي مدينه ام درمان السودانيه شاهد
على الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع حيث لا تزال حتى اليوم اصوات
الاشتراكات تسمع من مبنى سلاح المهندسين
القريب من الحي
المبادرات المفروض يكون بالضغط
مبادرات يكون في ضغط عديل على الجيش عليه
دعم ناس يستمعوا سياسيين من عساكر من
كلهم يتكتبوا عشان ينجحوا المبادره ايا
كانت هذه المبادره في سبيلنا بس توقف
الحرب وربنا يحفظ السودان لانه السودان ما
بستاهلوا سودانيين المفروض
الكلام ده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي ملف الهدنه المعطل اكدت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا في تصريحات لصحيفه
العربي نيوز اكدت ان على طرفي الصراع في
السودان الاتفاق على وقف دائم لاطلاق
النار وحل الخلافات بخيار المفاوضات تخاف
اضافت ايضا ان روسيا تبذل كل الجهود
اللازمه لضمان سلامه المواطنين الروس
الموجودين حاليا في السودان مشيره الى ان
بلادها على اتصال دائم مع جميع الدول ذات
الصله بما في ذلك المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
قبل ذلك انا اشهد امين وعامن اويم المتحده
عن مقابله خاصه مع العربيه نشد السودانيين
للعوده الى الحوار واكد ان الامم المتحده
ستعمل بكل جهدها للوصول لحل لازمه السودان
اسمح لي قبل ان نبدا ان ابعث رساله للشعب
السوداني لكل السودانيين الذين يسمعون اود
ان اعبر عن تضامن العميق وتضامن الامم
المتحده عندما كنت المفوضه الاعلى للاجئين
زرت السودان عده مرات وكنت مندهشا من حسن
الضيافه لدى الشعب السوداني كنا نرى
لاجئين من تشاد واريتيريا واحيانا
يشاطرونهم بما توفر لديهم من موارد من
خلال نظام يعتمد على الاخويه رؤيه هذا
الشعب الكريم والشجاع وهو يعاني امر يبعث
على الصدمه ويزعجني للغايه هناك جمله من
الامور التي يجب ان نقدمها الامم المتحده
لن تتخلى عن السودان وستفعل كل ما بوسعها
من اجل تامين الظروف الامنيه لتقديم الدعم
الانساني للش عب السوداني المفوضيه العليا
لشؤون اللاجئين التي عملت بها لمده عقد من
الزمن فاعله هناك وستضمن استقبال اللاجئين
هذا صراع يجب ان ينتهي وسنفعل كل ما
بوسعنا للتواصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
ليعود هذا البلد الى الحوار والاستقرار
وتمهيد الطريق الانتقال الديمقراطي الشعب
السوداني كان يحارب من اجل هذا الامر
وفي مقابله اخرى مع العربيه اكدت مندوبه
بريطانيا في الامم المتحده ان بلادها تهدف
للحصول على دعم مجلس الامن لمقترحات
الاتحاد الافريقي وايجاد فيما يخص الوضع
الحالي في السودان
ما نود فعله هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل
من مجلس الامن لمقترحات ايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي للتقدم نحو وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم
العوده للعمليه السياسيه
الامين العام المتحده تحدث ايضا عن عدم
حصوله حتى الان على تفاصيل مبادره منظمه
هي واحده من مكونات الاليه الثلاثيه التي
تطم ايضا الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
التغيير التالي مشاهدينا يقصد لنا مزيدا
من التفاصيل حول الاليه الثلاثيه واللجنه
الرباعيه وما تحاول فعله لحل صرع الدائري
حتى قبل اندلاعه
قبل اكثر من ثلاث سنوات فشل التوافق بين
المدنيين والمجلس العسكري في السودان في
اداره الفتره الانتقاليه وادى التوتر الذي
طغى بين المقاولين الاعتقال المجلس
العسكري لعبد الله حمدوك رئيس الحكومه
انذاك ووضعه قيد الاقامه الجبريه وبدا
المشهد في السودان شديد الضبابيه والتعقيد
فسعت الاليه الثلاثيه في السودان والمؤلفه
من ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده
ورئيسي بعثه
والاتحاد الافريقي بالاضافه الى الهيئه
الحكوميه لتنميه وسط وشرق افريقيا ايجاد
الى ايجاد حلول تمهد الاتفاق ايطالي بين
القوى المدنيه والعسكريه في السودان
يتناول قضايا جوهريه تشمل تشكيل حكومه
مدنيه والاتفاق على قضيه العداله
الانتقاليه وتقييم اتفاقيه السلام وكذلك
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري لكن اصطدمت
الاليه الثلاث كثيره ابرزها ارتبط بسنوات
دمج الدعم السريع داخل مؤسسه الجيش كما
واجهت معضله انسحاب الجيش من الحوار ما
اجبر الاليه على تعليقه عقب هذا التعقيد
نشطت المجموعه الرباعيه في السودان والتي
تتشكل من السعوديه والامارات والولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا في محاوله مع الاليه
الثلاثيه في لعب دور اكبر في الوساطه بين
المكون المدني والعسكري لتقريب وجهات
النظر وايجاد ارضيه مشتركه تسمح لها
بتسهيل الحصول على الدعم الذي يحتاجه
السودان لمواجهه ازماته الاقتصاديه حنان
المصري العربيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات